vou falar pra começar de novo é um bom
dia tudo bom
eu adoro conferências como ted dias como
hoje que a gente fica cheio de
inspiração de criatividade de energia
mas no entanto eu queria hoje trazer um
assunto que pouco se fala em
conferências como é se a depressão e
para tanto eu quero compartilhar com
vocês uma história pessoal muito pessoal
minha
poucas coisas me dão tanta alegria da
minha vida quando eu descobri o que é
ser humano é aquela vontade de viver
aquela alegria como a gente consegue
descobrir o que é a consciência que é
estar vivo como é conseguir entrar em
harmonia de entrar em equilíbrio em
todos os pilares que constituem o que é
ser humano corpo mente e espírito
e nessa busca que eu venho me dedicando
a minha vida já há alguns anos eu
comecei a perceber algumas coisas dentro
de mim
a primeira delas é como se tivesse um
buraco é bem tranquilo meu peito
esse buraco era como se fosse um buraco
negro que era capaz de tirar toda a
energia tudo minha felicidade nos
momentos mais inoportunos e buscando tem
uma inquietação quanto à s a esse
sentimento eu comecei a descobrir
algumas coisas e isso me levou a um
retiro de meditação de dez dias de uma
técnica budista chamada vi passar e o
que acontece né eu antes de ir pra esse
retiro eu era um cara que não tinha
muita certeza da minha vida mas eu tinha
algumas é alguma certeza que basicamente
faziam eu serei eu acredito que todo
mundo aqui deve ter essa certeza como
por exemplo o amor que você tem pela sua
família a sua profissão o que você gosta
de fazer os seus hobbies
mas o que acontece que quando a gente
vai em um processo desse no retiro então
imagine um retiro de dez dias e não
podia falar e não podia ler não podia
escrever não podia nem fazer contato com
outra pessoa
eu não podia nem estava sem contato
nenhum com o mundo exterior
o que aconteceu foi que conforme eu fui
então entrando mais e mais a minha mente
meditando 11 horas cada dia no durante
10 dias tem magia dos das obras que
estava acordado 11 horas já estava de
olho fechado conforme então eu comecei a
perceber e eu fui mais fundo
além da superficialidade do dia a dia
além do facebook do instagram do
whatsapp aquelas mensagens que nos deixa
malucos e o que aconteceu longe da
superficialidade do dia a dia eu comecei
a perceber que eu não era os meus
pensamentos
eu não era minha mente eu era algo muito
maior do que minha mente meus
pensamentos
eu estava tão identificado com a minha
mente com meus pensamentos que eu não
tinha essa percepção
nós todos temos isso nós percebemos os
pensamentos vindo voltando e muitas
vezes o que acontece é que esses
pensamentos são muito antagônicos um
bando da gente pra direita osman agente
pesqueira uns mandam a gente tomar
decisões por amor outros por ódio e tem
sempre essa batalha acontecendo aqui
dentro da gente não sabe dizer o que que
acontece né e isso gera confusão isso
gera sofrimento isso gera angústia e mas
eu queria compartilhar com vocês uma
descoberta que eu fiz também a respeito
disso por exemplo por que isso acontece
porque nós temos esses pensamentos tão
divergentes dentro da nossa mente pensa
comigo
nós seres humanos somos seres biológicos
e nós estamos muito desconectados com a
natureza
e antes que vocês vão falar é o cara foi
o rio pro retirou né natureza que eu
garanto que vocês não sou místicos em
alternativa e de hip natureba nenhuma
coisa dessas
o que eu quero tentar pra vocês é para o
fato de que nós somos seres biológicos
esse é um fato em si nós somos seres
biológicos
nós somos a natureza o que acontece é
que o tempo inteiro nós estamos envoltos
em ambientes como esses ambientes que
são artificiais pensa como isso aqui é
uma construção claro usamos matérias
primas usamos insumos construímos isso
aqui uma nova realidade mas essa sala
que é um ambiente artificial
pense na natureza como ela é é pura ego
do jeito que ela é perfeita o universo
árvores folhas chuvas ventos gelo água
vapor
talvez até o antagonismo falar isso mas
a única lei imutável da natureza é a
impermanência o que acontece quando a
gente vive em ambientes urbanos em
ambientes artificiais como esses é que
eles nos afetam de maneira que a gente
não imagina que isso todos
ambientes artificiais são estáticos eles
são imutáveis eles não mudam não são
como a natureza que está sempre em
constante mudança e isso influencia em
como nós somos influencia porque desde
pequenos como o gustavo falou nós somos
ensinados a buscar uma definição para
quem nós somos e toda vez que nós
buscamos quem nós somos e adotamos
alguma coisa que decidimos ser x y ou z
nós já baixamos para nossa mente é pro
hd no nosso disco rígido toda uma série
de regras e comportamentos já cágados e
cuspidas pela sociedade
nessa hora é que já baixamos tudo isso
nós deixamos de é ser humanos nós
perdemos a beleza do que é viver do quê
é se a beleza da natureza em permanente
e isso nos agride uma vez que você
escolheu essa profissão sua escolha
sexual que o que quer que você seja que
defina você você não pode mudar né mesmo
e foi isso é a minha grande descoberta
do retiro
eu descobri que todas as minhas certezas
não era certeza chega como um bom
engenheiro formado nessa faculdade e
corta tudo igual a zero mas na hora que
você corta tudo igual a zero o que sou
eu né
se todas as certezas que definiam quem
era eu não são certezas
como é que eu posso definir quem sou eu
nessa hora
aí sim a depressão bateu foi um período
difícil doloroso
eu me eu praticamente morre e renasce eu
passei por um processo de reconstrução
total ninguém que todo mundo fala que é
muito bonito a inovação diz construção
mas se consola de verdade que você ver
como é que é não é legal e vou te falar
talvez o pior de tudo isso o pior de
toda essa experiência é justamente ter
nascido numa cultura ocidental como a
nossa com valores ocidentais
por que falar entre familiares amigos
não foi uma nem duas pessoas que me
sugeriram procurar uma ajuda né afinal
num mal tinha vontade de sair da cama
se não fosse uma posição de bolinha
embaixo do cobertor da cama não era o
suficiente e não com mal consegui
assistir um filme tudo me fazia muito
mal
a matrix e fazer muito mal e é óbvio né
é claro o típico da nossa cultura isso
afinal só tem algum problema eu vou
pagar meus quadros e meios consensuais
uma consulta em 20 minutos o cara vai
conseguir descobrir exatamente quem eu
sou a pessoa que eu sou ele vai me dar
algum medicamento e pronto vai resolver
o que acontece nesse nessa hora é que os
medicamentos nada mais são do que um
atalho
eles podem até deixar melhor mas isso
vai depois aparecer de novo pode ter
certeza doenças reumáticas câncer mais
de pressão mais ansiedade
se eu tivesse nascido numa aldeia
indígena por exemplo sabe qual seria o
tratamento
eles vão me colocar numa hora como essa
no escuro e eu me alimentar de tempos em
tempos para garantir que tem as duas
funções vitais estavam gols e eu sou eu
e é sair de lá
depois de muita meditação depois de
muito entendimento do que eu sou de
verdade a nossa sociedade é assim né ai
no não posso ficar triste me dá um
remedinho aí não posso dor de cabeça dá
o remédio é preciso o preciso continuar
com a minha vida é preciso continuar a
trabalhar tem que pagar as contas
nós não podemos usar ao luxo de afundar
na tristeza de aprender com ela isso
como eu falei vem dos nossos valores
ocidentais nós confundimos conforto com
felicidade
nós estamos na ilusão de conforto
quentin da cama é a felicidade
facilidade felicidade são palavras muito
parecidas mas não são iguais pense nisso
né
e quando eu percebi tudo isso comecei a
perceber que estava vivendo uma ilusão
construída pela minha mente uma ilusão
que todo mundo aqui compartilha não se
engane você também para faz parte disso
nós vivemos num mundo que é construído
pela nossa mente e se vocês dúvida vou
te dar um exemplo bem prático agora para
você perceber isso
por exemplo agora que estou falando com
vocês é porque eu tenho uma coisa aqui
dentro da minha mente que eu quero
expressar o que eu preciso falar pra
vocês mas no momento em que o transforma
em palavras o que está acontecendo
dentro da minha mente já não é
exatamente o que está na minha mente é
no máximo uma representação grosseira do
que está se passando aqui dentro de você
por sua vez na hora que você ouve o que
eu tô falando as palavras que eu tô
falando você aplica o seu filtro como
nosso amigo hipopótamo aqui a sua lente
de mundo
afinal você é uma pessoa diferente pois
é fruto de todo mas sua experiência
tudo o que você viveu né cada um é
diferente cada um enxerga as coisas de
um jeito na hora que você então aplicar
o seu filho já é uma coisa completamente
diferente é como se estivesse brincando
o telefone sem fio é de quatro fases o
tempo inteiro só que nós não estamos
conscientes
quem sabe agora você esteja um pouquinho
mais um exemplo de que vivemos uma
ilusão por exemplo quem lembra desse
caso do da imagem do vestido
os viam a imagem branca e dourada outros
viam preto e azul
isso estava muito com muita confusão a
gente né mas na verdade essa imagem foi
a primeira vez que algo se tornou
popular o suficiente pra mostrar pra
todo mundo que nem todo mundo vê o mundo
do mesmo jeito
o mais legal de tudo isso é que esse
vestido no dia time de futebol ele não
tinha religião ele não tinha partido
político não era uma discussão atrelado
à religião política o futebol então dava
para se discutir de um jeito um
pouquinho mais saudável o que aconteceu
com a mente de muitas pessoas eu eu me
incluo nisso quando aconteceu isso é
você ver a imagem enxerga uma cor e
passa por seu colega ele vê outra coisa
que acontecia era mais ou menos assim o
primeiro vinha negação
você falava ah não podem falar que estou
certo não é não certeza o vestido azul
vestido azul não pode ser outra cor é
azul
se o fla no rio branco né miranda que
ele viu por acaso é assim e pronto e
negação é a primeira parte mas é mais
fácil mais cômoda nós não saímos da
nossa zona de conforto nós estamos
fechados a todo o tipo de possibilidades
e nós continuamos com a nossa visão não
temos evolução temos nada
logo em seguida a nossa mente começa a
evoluir um pouco mais é quando ela passa
de da negação ela passa de procurar
referências externas
ela então começa a olhar pra dentro nós
então começamos a pensar puxa não terei
mas será que sou eu
já que uma com um problema comigo porque
eu vi azul
será que é porque não li os livros na
faculdade eu não li os livros certos eu
num estou fazendo meus exercícios vão
tomando água de manhã que é é a já sei
já sei é problema meu olho eu vou ligar
pro hospital vou resolver isso rápido
vai dizer que tá acontecendo
nessa hora nós já começamos a perceber
que tanto negar quando procurar soluções
externas
de nada vai adiantar para esse problema
quem sabe agora é hora de olhar pra
dentro
quem sabe perceber que temos podemos ter
algum problema
e finalmente a gente chega no último
estágio que é a aceitação é aceitar que
de repente puxa o fulano eu não posso
usar o plano de referência eu tenho que
ser sincero comigo mesmo e é uma pessoa
diferente como eu disse outra pessoa
outro outra educação outro modo de viver
a claro é se o se fulano torce pra que
ele tinha o pior porém de bom jesus é
claro que ele estava em um vestido
branco sabe se ele é capaz de torcer pra
esse time que mais sabe que mais do que
vai passar na cabeça dele o que eu
queria assim pra fechar tudo isso eu
queria deixar com vocês quatro conceitos
sobre essa experiência de meditar dez
dias e que a depressão nitroso
o primeiro deles era frisar pra vocês
uma vez por todas que conforto não há
felicidade lembre-se facilidade não é
felicidade
eu desde que eu voltei que eu passei por
essa experiência tenho feito meu
possível para tentar mostrar para as
pessoas e despertar elas a ilusão do
conforto
a segunda coisa que eu queria falar pra
vocês é sobre espiritualidade
espiritualidade espírito parte
espiritual é uma coisa que já deixa as
pessoas me estranha celas ficam na rede
elas fogem à janela gol fica uma estréia
é como se eu tivesse falado que eu vejo
vestindo azul ea pessoa viu um vestido
branco
todo mundo fica meio estranho mas porque
isso né espiritualidade gente nada mais
é do que autoconhecimento
só isso talvez eu falando hoje não de
convença a comprar todos os livros do
despachou para o é cachorro não te
convence a se inscrever no workshop de
meditação não nada disso
talvez não esteja na hora talvez você
tem que passar por uma experiência como
eu passei pra começar a cultivar esse
lado espiritual sejuc espiritual for pra
você
mas do mesmo jeito que eu peço assim eu
não estou pedindo para você comprar o
que eu tô falando num tom pedindo pra
você
e buscar isso não muito pelo contrário
eu quero que você desconfia de verdade
não como eu tô falando desconfie
mas da mesma maneira que eu peço que
você desconfiar de tudo isso que falei
na desilusão do retiro de tudo isso eu
peço que você desconfia de tudo o resto
desconfie não acredite que você compra
uma nova casa um novo carro vai fazer
mais feliz
não acredite que um trabalho que você
vai conseguir um milhão de reais em um
ano vai fazer mais feliz
não acredite acredite em você acredite
acredite nos seus sentimentos acredite
no amor
sente se em silêncio começa a perceber
mais quem é você não acredite que toda
vez que você estiver entediado você
tirar o seu celular e fica rolando
facebook nas redes sociais vai te fazer
melhor
não acredite também não acredite que
trabalhar 12 horas por dia vai fazer
melhor
não acredite em mim a terceira coisa é
que não existe alegria sem tristeza
profunda
como eu disse antes a nossa sociedade de
valores ocidentais parece não estar
disposta a pagar o preço da tristeza
ninguém ficar triste né
ah eu tô triste de um remedinho aqui aí
tô triste acho que vou dar uma volta vou
tomar uma cerveja ou fazer alguma coisa
é nessas horas que a gente tem que fazer
o oposto a gente tem que cultivar triste
a gente tem que curtir a tristeza e
entender o que ela tem a nos ensinar
eu garanto para vocês que no último mês
em tristeza profunda eu aprendi mais
sobre mim mesmo do que no último ano
inteiro
a tristeza é muito mais poderosa do que
nós imaginamos que a vida é assim
isso aqui é o gráfico a nossa vida é a
zona de conforto a tristeza é altos e
baixos picos e vales alegrias e
tristezas o tempo inteiro
cultive a tristeza é mais poderosa do
que você imagina se você precisar de
mais alguma coisa para ilustrar a isso o
filme da pizza divertidamente fantástico
ele mostra isso como ninguém eles
fizeram um trabalho incrível ea quarta
coisa é que assim como nós temos uma já
baixamos uma uma série de regras e
comportamentos sobre a palavra
espiritualidade nós também fazemos isso
com meditação
ah eu vou editar vou ficar calmo vou
ficar sozinho
tranquilo a gente vê nada disso o que a
meditação é é nada mais do que uma
técnica quem puder a você a enxergar o
que acontece dentro de nós né
só isso como eu falei antes no começo
que nós temos sempre pensamentos
divergentes o que a meditação faz é
justamente tim poderá a observar essas
divergências que acontece dentro de você
pensa que o tempo inteiro você é luz e
sombra
você é bem você mal você tem tudo isso
dentro de você
nós somos tudo isso e o que a meditação
faz é justamente da uma técnica pra você
observar tudo isso se você criar
harmonia entre essas divergências
essa obra mostra isso como qualquer um
nunca vi uma coisa que mostrasse também
como essa obra essa obra por acaso se
chama harmonia dos dragões do android
jones
então quem sabe está na hora de você
começar a harmonizar os dragões internos
e com esse pouco a pouco com esse
entendimento com essa observação do
grupo d da harmonização dentro de você
o buraco no peito não é que eu falei pra
vocês o começo da palestra vai aos
poucos se transformando na força maior
que existe né a maior força que nós
seres humanos talvez conseguimos sentir
presenciar viver a força que nos
diferencia de qualquer outro conjunto de
átomos e moléculas que existem por aí
o amor então senhoras e senhores meninos
e meninas se tem alguma coisa que eu
quero que vocês fiquem hoje é escutar o
seu coração muito obrigado